>>Male Presenter: Good morning and welcome
to this edition of Authors at Google.
I'm Dan Russell, I'm from the search quality
group and it's my distinct pleasure to introduce
my friend, Chip Conley, today who's gonna
be talking about something I think we all
actually need to know a little bit more about.
Now I could tell you a lot about Chip but
I won't because you're at Google and so you
can, presumably, can find things like he's
a rebel entrepreneur, he's done fantastic
work rehabbing and starting up hotels all
around the place, he's won fantastic awards,
he's a really interesting guy.
But you can look that up.
What I wanna do it tell you a little bit about
the topic of today's talk.
He's a practiced author having written multiple
books and you might recognize some of his
slacker co-authors.
[pause]
So he's done this before and we started talking
a while ago about what would it mean to write
a book about equations about emotions.
And we talked about that for a while and when
he first said that I thought of an equation
like this: this is Schrödinger's Wave Equation
and I thought, "It's gonna describe the waves
of emotion.
It's gonna be a quantum mechanical view of
the way people act and behave."
He said, "No, no, no, no, no [chuckles] That's
not the right approach."
So he said, "What about a beautiful equation;
we want simple, elegant simplicity."
And I thought of this equation which many
of you will recognize which is all those things
but it's not for people, that's really for
mathematicians.
[laughter]
Right?
We have a distinct sub-species here.
>>female #1: Former mathematicians.
>>male #1: [inaudible] mathematicians.
>>Dan Russell: We're encompassing we take
all kinds of people here.
And so I started thinking, "Well, maybe we
can describe emotions as systems of equations
like this."
"No, no, no, Dan."
And so the more, we talked the more I started
to realize that what Chip was about is trying
to describe these sort of neat, conceptual
nuggets of information that describe terms
about emotions a little bit like Ohm's law.
The simplest, physical law described as an
equation which gets represented often as this
sort of triangular model that allows you to
very quickly see the relationship between
the different terms.
When Chip and I were talking about emotional
equations, I realized that's what he means
by equation; it's a model of the relationship
between these conceptual categories.
By this book, he's expressing this, I think,
very elegant and beautiful notion that we
can have this embedded in our belief system
and understand ourselves far better than you
would normally have without this.
So Chip is my Burning Man buddy, he's a Maslowtopian,
he's an author, he's my friend.
I'm very proud to introduce Chip Conley.
[applause]
>>Chip Conley: It is very strange to come
to Google and lecture you on math. [laughs]
[laughter]
But let me say thank you, Dan.
I loved the pyramid, I left the Ohm's law
in the form of the pyramid because for those
of you who know a little bit about my last
book I am a Maslowtopian.
I'm a big believer in Maslow's hierarchy of
needs and that led to me writing the book
Peak: How Great Companies Get their Mojo from
Maslow.
So I'm gonna start today with a little video
and it's gonna, it's a little, maybe a little
hard to actually see but it's gonna give you
a frame of reference for my key theme of the
day and so let's see if we can make this work
and if it actually is visible up there.
Here we go.
[video]
>> ticket agent: Hello there, checking any
bags?
>>passenger: Yeah just two.
>>ticket agent: Okay.
The second bag will be $100.
>>passenger: Uh –
[talking in background]
[pause]
okay, just one bag then.
>>ticket agent: Here's your boarding pass
sir.
Gate 83.
Enjoy your flight.
[music in background]
[sound of plane taking off]
[man singing]
I wanted love, I needed love
Most of all, most of all.
Someone said true love was dead
And I'm bound to fall, bound to fall for you.
Oh what can I do?
Yeah
Take my badge but my heart remains
Loving you, baby child
Tighten up on your reigns
You're runnin' wild, runnin' wild
It's true
[music in background]
[telephone sounds in background]
Sick for days, so many ways
I'm achin' now, I'm achin' now
It's times like these, I need relief
Please show me how, oh show me how
To get right
[music in background]
[sound of horn honking]
[crickets chirp; owls hoot]
Living just to keep going
Goin' just to be sane
All the while I know
It's such a shame
I don't need to get steady
I know just how I feel
I'm telling you to be ready
My dear
[music in background]
[sound of door closing]
[music fades]
[laughter]
>>Chip Conley: I wish the sound and the visuals
were a little bit better but I did bring a
friend here, who's the star of our show.
[laughter]
So --
some of you don't know you have emotional
baggage.
And most of you don't know that within your
emotional baggage --
[sound of suitcase being opened]
you have emotional baggage.
[laughter]
There's in fact bags within the bags.
What I'm gonna talk about today is --
[sound of suitcase being set down]
is the idea that math can be used in the form
of relationships, understanding the relationships
of your emotions.
Now that may be a blast from this idea to
those of you who are the Ph.
Ds in math in the room, and when I first brought
it up to Dan, Dan did scratch his head a little
bit and sort of was trying to understand what
I meant.
And I'm gonna tell you my story today because
it's the story of, --it's a personal story--,
of how I needed a lighthouse when I was in
a very difficult place as a CEO of a company
and felt like I was supposed to have my life
together, but my life was falling apart.
And somehow understanding the idea of an emotion
as an equation became a bit of a mantra for
me.
The word Mantra, Meng could teach you this
because he's good at this stuff; mantra technically
means 'mind instrument'.
And so what I needed was something to be the
mind instrument for me when I was going through
a lot of difficult emotions.
So --
[pause]
I've been a hotelier for 24 years, 25 years.
24 years of it I was the CEO company Joie
de Vivre.
Many of you have probably stayed at the Hotel
Avante, one of our hotels in Mountain View;
we're the second largest boutique hotelier
in the world now, Joie de Vivre is.
We're based in San Francisco.
People show up at our hotel front desks with
their baggage, some of it's not physical [laughs]
some of it's the emotional baggage type [chuckles]
and what I'm hoping today is that in the course
of the time together that I'm gonna help you
understand what some of the baggage that you
may have goin' on in your own life and how
you make sense of the relationship of the
ingredients in essence that create anxiety
or happiness or despair.
But first let me give you a little background.
So as I mentioned before and as Dan mentioned,
I'm a big fan of Abe Maslow.
I took one, a grand total of one psychology
class as Stanford.
I went to Stanford undergrad, I went to Stanford
Business School, I took a class with Zimbardo,
Phil Zimbardo, Phillip Zimbardo.
So he was my psychology professor and the
one thing I remember from psychology one,
in college was Abe Maslow because he was the
guy who talked about best practices in human
behavior as opposed to worst practices.
He's also the one who came up a great quote,
"If the only tool you have is a hammer, everything
starts to look like a nail."
And he said that to the psychology profession,
he said, "Why is it that we think that all
people are broken?
Why don't we study the flourishing people?
And by studying the people who are flourishing
or self actualizing in life maybe we can learn
something that we can apply to everybody else."
And that's why he created the hierarchy of
needs.
And 10 years ago, in the wake of the dot com
buzz to 9/11 and you name it, everything that
could go wrong did go wrong.
And here in the Bay Area for those of you
who were living here in the Bay Area 10 years
ago, we went through a bit of a minor depression,
economic depression based upon what happened
in the dot com bust.
Well, at the point we were the largest hotelier
in the Bay Area, we had no hotels outside
the Bay Area so we were in a lot of trouble.
We applied Maslow's hierarchy of needs to
our company and we tried to create a self-actualized
company and it worked.
We tripled in size, we had no layoffs, we
got the award for the highest customer satisfaction
award in the hospitality industry and after
Google, we came in second place for the best
place to work [chuckles]
[laughter]
in the San Francisco Bay Area, so thank you
Google.
[laughter]
[pause]
But that was the last downturn and this is
a tale of two downturns, two Jewish shrinks,
and two goys named Chip.
And the last downturn, I felt a bit like a
gladiator and my company Joie de Vivre lived
up to its name, Joy of Life, and we used Maslow
to get ourselves through it.
This downturn, I wasn't feeling so much that
way, I actually was feeling quite the opposite.
I felt more like a prisoner than a gladiator.
And so I started reading this book by Viktor
Frankl called Man's Search for Meaning.
How many of you are familiar with the book?
So a handful of you folks.
So Man's Search for Meaning was written by
Viktor Frankl in the 1940's.
He was a Jewish psychologist in Vienna in
the 1930's and his basic premise as a psychologist
was that the fuel of life is meaning; that's
what creates the sense of why we show up for
our lives each day.
And then, ironically, and sort of as if God
as a weird sense of humor, he was put in a
concentration camp to see if his theory of
meaning being the fuel of life actually made
sense.
He ended up writing about it and I started
reading this book in early 2008.
Peak, my book came out in September of 2007
and I was goin' around the country and giving
about 80 speeches a year on self-actualization
in the context of work, including here at
Google.
But in early 2008 I was very clear that my
life wasn't, I was like the guy going out
and talking about self actualization but not
feeling it --
[laughter]
which was a really awkward, it's like the
preacher going out and giving his sermon and
then going out and doin' something that we
won't talk about here, you know what those
preachers do.
[laughter]
And I ended up starting to read this book
because I felt like I was a bit of a prisoner
to my identity and to what was the upcoming
downturn that I could sort of see.
'Cause the hotel industry basically can see
downturns.
You see downturns faster than we do because
of the analytics associated with what goes
on with Google.
We see it pretty quickly though, too, because
one of the first things people cut back on
in terms of spending is travel.
But there was a quote in Man's Search for
Meaning that really spoke to me on a deep
level and it was this one: "Between stimulus
and response there is a space.
In that space is our power to choose our response
and in our response lies our growth and our
freedom."
So for me, I mean like who's the whining CEO,
Chip Conley, up there like being upset about
his life.
Well, I wasn't whining about it.
In fact, I had this growing divide between
my public image and my private reality and
when that happens that's actually quite often
when depression and a few other things can
kick in.
Well, I had other friends in my life who had
a growing divide between their public image
and their private reality too.
Over the course of 2008 to 2010, I had five
friends commit suicide, take their lives,
and one of them who my friend Greg Jones who's
here today knows well was my friend, Chip,
and Greg's friend, Chip.
This is not me, this is guy named Chip Hankins
and my talks and my book are really dedicated
to him.
He was very close friend with both Greg and
me.
And he was one of those guys who sort of,
you know people in your life who are sort
of the light of the party, they're the light
of your life and they're deep thinkers; Chip
was all of those things, in some ways he was
a mirror for how I aspired to be in my own
life.
And we shared the same name, we both actually
owned bars and we went for long periods of
time, we didn't drink.
I mean there was a lot of similarities between
us.
On April 30, 2008, I got a call from his boss,
the president of his insurance company, because
for 12 years Chip was our insurance broker
for Joie de Vivre, and I got a call and found
out that Chip had actually taken his life.
And so going to the funeral, the memorial
service at Greg's ranch actually and hearing
about a friend and talking about your friend
who'd taken their life, it's hard, it's very
hard and when they have the same name you
have, it's a little bit harder.
And when you're sort of in the throes of your
own depression, the early stages for me, it
made it a lot to handle.
So I felt after that experience, I really
needed to make sense of this Man's Search
for Meaning a little bit more.
But then I had my own experience, I had two
and a half months after the memorial service
for Chip, I was in St. Louis again which is
where I was when I got the news about Chip.
I was giving a speech about self actualization
and at the end of my speech I went flat line.
I was on stage giving a speech, fortunately
I sat down because I had a broken ankle at
the time, sat down and the second person I
was signing a book for the person said to
me, "You look awfully white."
And I just went unconscious and within about
five minutes the paramedics were there and
they put heart monitors on me and that's when
I went flat line.
So between that and a bunch of other things
happening in my life, a long term relationship
ending, my son going to San Quentin wrongfully,
he ended up getting out after being eight
months in San Quentin.
A federal judge let him out but [chuckles]
having your son go to San Quentin for eight
months is not a fun thing.
And then we were running out of money, as
a company, and I was running out of money,
personally.
So I took Man's Search for Meaning and I said,
"You know, what I want this, I wanna understand
why I wanna continue to stand and be on this
earth and I don't wanna go the path that Chip
and others felt like they had to take."
So I turned this famous book on meaning into
an equation and I am not a math major, I am
so far from a math [chuckles] major, but what
I needed was something to help to explain
the relationship between the components that
were creating some depression and despair
in my life.
So this was the equation: Despair equals suffering
minus meaning.
It's a little bit like sacred algebra.
[chuckles]
Suffering was the constant, if you're going
through a really rough time in your life suffering
is a constant; if you're a Buddhist its first
noble truth of Buddhism that suffering, Dukkha,
is ever present.
Having Meng in the front row is really hard,
it's very distracting right now.
[laughs]
[laughter]
[pause]
Between Meng and between the Ph.
D. math people in the room, it's like okay
I am really setting myself up for failure
today.
[laughter]
No, but suffering is ever present when you're
going through a really rough time and the
funny thing about it, the sad thing about
it is we tend to actually focus on it and
when you're focusing on it you're not making
it any better.
What this helped me to see is that suffering
is the constant and meaning's the variable
and if you put your attention on the meaning
and increase the meaning, the despair goes
down.
And that was my own little mantra that I was
using in the summer of 2008 after my flat
line experience when I was goin' through a
bunch of other crap.
And it was working for me because what it
helped me to get back to is, like, what's
the lesson, with all this stuff that's goin'
on, what's the lesson?
I also found a study, a really interesting
study, of women who grew up during the Civil
War, I'm sorry, during the Depression.
Women who grew up in the 1930s.
And what it showed was that women who actually
grew up in the 1930s in their formative years
later in life when they became a widow because
quite often they outlive their husband, they
actually had built, during the 1930s in their
teens and their 20s, resilience, independence,
courage.
They were better able to handle being a widow
than the women who didn't grow up during the
Depression.
Major study by Elker and Lighter that was
done like 10, 20 years ago.
So I said, "Okay maybe I'm actually in emotional
boot camp right now.
And maybe during emotional boot camp, I'm
actually building some emotional muscles that
I have but I hadn't been working out in a
while."
And so that's what I started to think about.
And then in November of 2008, when the world
was starting to fall apart in a faster pace,
it was two months after Lehman Brothers went
bankrupt.
And in the hotel business, people in our company
could say, "My God, we're about to go into
our second once-in-a-lifetime downturn in
the same decade."
I was supposed to give a speech to the top
18, I'm sorry the top 80 executives in my
company at the Dream Inn in Santa Cruz which
is, if you haven't been there lately, it's
a hotel we renovated a couple years ago.
It's sort of cool.
And we were all sitting looking at the view
and everybody was looking for the cheerleading
speech from Chip the CEO.
And instead of giving the cheerleading speech,
I threw it away because what I saw in the
room was 80 people who were full of suffering.
And so I just said, on an easel, I just wrote
up my equation and I said, "I wanna just share
for the next hour my equation with you because
I actually think the worse thing I could do
right now is to be up here cheerleading.
And I, instead, think we need to do what Abe
Maslow talked about is we need to have a good
exercise in psycho hygiene.
[chuckles]
Psycho hygiene basically, means in Maslow
term, it means that when you're going through
a really difficult time, you learn how to
shower together.
[chuckles] Because frankly what happens in
an organization during difficult times is
there's a lot of stress, it becomes a bit
of a sweat box, and actually people sort of
go at each other instead of actually sort
of figuring out how to actually make people
feel a little bit better.
So I felt like what we needed to do is actually
be authentic and vulnerable and allow people
to talk about their fears about being a general
manager of a hotel that has just two years
ago got through the last downturn and now
we're going into another one.
So an hour later after the talk and people
conversing and people telling their stories
someone came up to me and gave me a whisper
and said, "Do you have an equation for jealousy?"
[laughs]
[laughter]
And someone else came up and said, "Do you
have one for anxiety?"
And then the smartest one in the room came
up and said, "Do you have one for happiness?"
So I said, "This is interesting."
I created this equation for myself and then
I shared it with my senior executives and
it seemed to actually resonate so I said,
"I wanna learn more about emotions."
This is Isaac Newton, really smart dude [laughs]
I mean come on now you know that he actually
helped to invent calculus, I don't know if
you can invent calculus, but he was able to
sort of help us understand calculus; gravity,
he didn't invent it but he helped us explain
it; the telescope.
But you probably didn't know that Isaac Newton
also created the color wheel and helped us
to understand that if you combine red plus
blue you get purple.
So I didn't know that Isaac Newton did that.
Well as I started to look at the color wheel
I started to see well this idea of despair
equals suffering minus meaning is sort of,
it's like an emotion wheel.
And I did my deep dive, I did sort of my Ph.
D. in psychology and I spent the next year
and a half to two years learning and reading
about 150 books and 300 studies in psychology.
And I learned about this guy Dr. Robert Plutchik
who had created in the 1980's something called
the emotion wheel.
You can't really see it very well up here
but if you add joy plus anticipation it equals
optimism.
And he created this emotion wheel and the
reason that it never got a lot of play within
the psychology academic community, is because
back in the 1980s, if you were doing backwater
academic studies in psychology you were focusing
on emotions because emotions was not a very
well respected piece of the psychology world;
today it is, but back then it wasn't.
So it never really got very far.
But I said to myself, "Wow, I guess there's
some history of the psychology academic world
looking at the idea of equations for emotions.
In fact, I started to learn a little bit more
about the happiness equation that Martin Seligman,
Marty Seligman, famous positive psychologist
had created where he said, "Happiness is 50
percent your biological set point, 10 percent
your circumstances, and 40 percent your intention."
So I decided to do a little bit more research
and I decided to go out and study happiness.
Now I could have gone to Disneyland [chuckles]
[laughter]
the happiest place on earth which is where
I grew up, I grew up like within five minutes
of Disneyland --
[pause]
instead I went to Bhutan.
Why?
Anybody know why Bhutan and happiness?
Yes.
>>male #2: Gross national happiness index.
>>Chip Conley: Yeah, the gross national happiness
index.
So 40 years ago, the 17 year old King of Bhutan
was in India and someone said to him, "What's
the GDP or actually the GNP because GDP hadn't
been created yet, what's the GNP for Bhutan?"
And the 17 year old king looked at the Indian
journalist and said, "Why do we care about
GNP, why don't we care about gross national
happiness?"
Now, at the time, it didn't take a lot of
note, people didn't take much note of it but
40 years later there are now 50 countries
in the world that are studying their gross
national happiness in some form with some
name.
Bhutan was the first one and because it's
sort of a really cool place, that's Bhutan,
that's Tiger's Nest in Bhutan.
I said, "I'm gonna go to Bhutan and I'm gonna
spend a week studying the gross national happiness
index there, get to know the Prime Minister,
get to know the people in the U.N. who are
there in Bhutan studying happiness and I'll
come back and then I'll go talk to a bunch
of other people on the happiness circuit."
[laughs]
[laughter]
So I did and I came back with this equation
and I was fortunate enough that a guy named
Chris Anderson, not Chris Anderson, the Wired
Chris Anderson, but Chris Anderson, the TED
Chris Anderson found out about my equation
and asked me to give a finale TED talk two
years ago at the TED conference and introduced
my happiness equation.
So this is a little bit of a mind tease, happiness
equals wanting what you have divided by having
what you want.
It comes back to a guy named Rabbi Hyman Schachtel
in 1954 said, "Happiness is not about having
what you want it's about wanting what you
have."
And it's learning to actually get to the practicing
of gratitude.
The psychology profession and those who actually
study happiness basically they all say, "The
fastest way to create happiness in the moment
when you're not feeling happy is to figure
out how to get to gratitude as quickly as
possible.
And it's not just the process of actually
getting to gratitude, it's also the practice
of expressing the gratitude.
Because actually just experiencing the gratitude
without expressing it is like wrapping a Christmas
present and not giving it.
[laughs]
[laughter]
So the idea of practicing gratitude is what
wanting what you have means.
So when you want what you have, you have a
tendency to practice gratitude, to feel and
appreciate what you have.
We, in the United States, get very wrapped
up in the denominator of this equation, the
pursuit of gratification; having what we want;
the act of going out and having what we want.
Let me tell you, I am a Type A person, I was
a CEO for 24 years, I went to Stanford, I
went to Stanford Business School, I am a pursuer
by nature.
So I'm not here to say that we should not
pursue happiness, it's actually in the Declaration
of Independence of our country.
But if you look at the dictionary definition
of pursuit in some dictionaries, the definition
of pursuit is to chase with hostility.
[laughs]
[laughter]
Do we chase happiness with hostility --
in the United States?
I think on occasion we do.
[laughter]
So in some ways, happiness is about how do
you practice gratitude and how to you be careful
about the pursuing of gratification?
For me, it's not about actually being a couch
potato and just writing in my gratitude journal
every day, I wouldn't be able to do that very
well.
But it is when I'm in that state of not feeling
very happy about something I can ask myself
this equation and the question, "How do I
get to gratitude right now?
How do I practice some gratitude?
And am I spending too much time in the denominator
in pursuing gratification?"
The book, this book Emotional Equations which
Books, Inc. is here so they've got, they've
got discount books, it's lovely that you,
Google, I think, subsidizes them right?
Well this book actually the first week it
was out it went on to the New York Times Best
Sellers List at number seven.
Of course I was, my immediate reaction was
I want number four next week.
[laughs] Because I was pursuing gratification
–
[pause]
and I saw it immediately and when I could
actually laugh at myself and say, "Damn, I
wrote a book about emotional equations and
actually did really well and my first reaction
when it did really well was, "I wanna be number
four."
[pause]
So that's how our mind works and it's been
working that way for a long time.
We know who this guy is.
What you didn't know about Socrates is he
was the first guy to ever go on a treadmill
and he was the first guy to buy Nikes.
[chuckles]
[laughter]
But Socrates once said, "He who is not contented
with what he has would not be contented with
what he would like to have."
So on a treadmill because most of you have
probably heard of the hedonic treadmill and
it's a treadmill that we all jump on and it's
the treadmill of gratification.
How do we go out and pursue our gratification,
how do we go out and get what we want, how
do we go out and if we've gotten this how
do we go out and get that?
And generally speaking for those of us who
are leaders we want people working for us
who have that mentality.
So I'm not saying we shouldn't actually have
the pursuit, what I am saying is when you're
not feeling happy, just know that this is
what's going on and it's been goin' on for
centuries, going back to Socrates' time.
So after getting despair and happiness [chuckles]
I'd gotten the two equations at the extremes
I started asking myself, "What's the number
one emotion that seems to be pervading organizational
culture in the United States in this recession?"
This is 2009 at this point.
[pause]
And this is it, it was anxiety, the number
one emotion in most organizations in the world,
especially in a recession.
There are two ingredients that represent,
according to anxiety researchers, 95 to 96
percent of the anxiety that we tend to feel:
it's what you don't know and what you can't
control; those are the two variables.
And so it's anxiety equals uncertainty times
powerlessness.
And it's not a plus it's a times because they
have a combustible effect.
And the truth is when you can take one of
them down closer to zero it actually does
help with the other and it helps to reduce
the anxiety.
So I decided to create a balance sheet, okay,
another thing I don't know much about, accounting.
I did go to Stanford Business School but I
hated accounting, didn't like math and I took
one psychology class, what the hell am I doin'
up here?
[chuckles] But you'll see this anxiety balance
sheet.
If you are struggling with something in your
life, in something that's making you a little
anxious, try this exercise: create four columns.
The first column is what do I know;
[pause]
second column is what don't I know about this
thing that's making me anxious;
[pause]
the third column is what can I influence;
and the fourth column is what can't I influence?
Okay let's see it altogether.
So the anxiety balance sheet says there are
four columns: columns one and columns three
here are the "good" columns, what I do know
and what I can influence.
Column two and four are the "bad" columns,
they're ones that actually create, they create
the uncertainty and powerlessness.
I've done this balance sheet with people and
leaders in companies from CBS to Nordstrom's
to Charles Schwab and what I've found is really
interesting, is when people do this exercise
75 to 80 percent of the people have more things,
more items in columns one and column three,
the "good" columns, the assets, than they
do in columns two and four.
But when you're anxious you tend to obsess
about what's in column two and column four.
So just actually getting it on paper helps
to take some of the anxiety away.
Secondly, you can look at column two and say,
"What don't I know?" and you could ask yourself,
"How could I go learn that?
Maybe I'll go to Google and maybe I can learn
something on Google."
Yes, that's one way.
Maybe you could ask your husband or your wife
if they're actually having an affair.
That's a novel idea or maybe you could ask
your boss are there gonna be layoffs and am
I gonna lose my job?
Now most of us think that actually asking
someone the answer to what do I not know,
like trying to take something from column
two to put it in column one is a really stupid
idea because why do I wanna know the answer.
Well, there's a study done, you probably heard
it before because it's sort of like one of
those sort of urban myth kinda studies, where
people had the choice of getting an electric
shock, there are only two choices you can
either get the electric shock now and it's
twice as painful as an electric shock you
can get in the next 24 hours.
So you get either an electric shock now and
you just know you got it over with or you
can get an electric shock in the next 24 hours
randomly when you're not expecting it.
So what did most people select?
What would you select, now or sometime in
the next 24 hours but half as painful?
Okay how many want now?
How many want sometime in the next 24 hours
randomly?
You're perfect two-thirds of you said that
you wanted it now and that's exactly what
the survey results showed is two-thirds of
the people want to get it over now why, because
mental stress is actually more painful than
physical stress, physical pain.
So what does that mean for us as leaders here?
That means that if you have bad news to give
and you have a sense that the people who work
with you are starting to get an inkling about
the bad news, give the bad news, get it out
there.
The anxiety shuts down the parts of your brain
that tend to be more creative and innovative,
you tend to spend your time in the amygdala
at the base of the brain, that caveman part
of your brain and not in the prefrontal cortex
where a lot of the reasoning and creativity
and innovation come from.
Alright, curiosity.
The founder of Sony once said, "Curiosity
is the fuel of creativity."
I agree.
Curiosity, Marty Seligman has also shown that
curiosity is what actually helps create resilience.
When people are resilient, it has a lot to
do with coming up with new ways to look at
something.
So I started saying, "Well, curiosity seems
like an interesting and a very appropriate
emotion or state of being to talk about here
at Google, it's a very curious place."
What I started to realize when I did my research
on curiosity is that people who tend to be
curious, strangely enough, and for those of
you in the room you're gonna sort of not believe
this but it's actually a study, it was in
the Economist, it was in the Economist it
must be true.
[laughs]
[laughter]
So I'm 51 years old.
Dan came to my 50th birthday party at Burning
Man and so I was 50 years old, just turned
50 in December of 2010, and I see the cover
of the Economist Magazine in December of 2010,
The Joy of Growing Old, I figure well this
is written for me, I better learn about it.
And there was this interesting graph in there
called the U-bend of life and it was self
reported well being in the United States.
And what it shows basically is the following,
most importantly I'm gonna tell you about
the curiosity that relates to it, is that
people tend to be happiest as adults when
they're in their college years 18 to 20 although
it sort of goes down each year, and then strangely
enough between about 25, 22, 24 and 34, 35
that's a 10 year period where people's happiness
is relatively stable and then the shit hits
the fan at age 35.
And between 35 and 50, how many of you are
35 to 50 here?
Okay I'm sorry.
[laughs]
[laughter]
It just gets worse every year.
[pause]
Now there's a bunch of reasons for this: kids
have somethin' to do with it interestingly
enough.
[laughter]
Disappointment has something to do with it,
it's the number one emotion that gets worse
each year between 35 and 50.
And then the other thing that's related to
this that actually sort of is relevant to
what happens at age 50 and beyond, starting
age 50 and beyond is each decade the happiness
goes up, which is odd because I think generally
we have historically thought that people in
their 70s and 80s are not very happy and what
newer evidence is showing is that actually
people get happier again.
Why?
Well the number one [chuckles] reason that,
the number one parallel for people who are
in their 18 to 20 year age and people who
are in their 70s and 80s is that they're curious.
Now I don't think of my parents as all that
curious in their mid-70's but the fact is
there is a difference between having a sense
of wonder and having a sense of awe.
People late in life, strangely enough, have
a sense of awe about life, more and more.
There's a weird sense that they are just a
small speck in a bigger, magnificent picture
and there's something beautiful about that
and something curious about it.
And there's people like Peter Drucker, you
may have heard of Peter Drucker, famous management
theorist, up 'til his dying day at age 95
every two years he would go out and study
something that had nothing to do with his
career, it could be Japanese Ikebana, it could
be American Civil War history, because what
he believed is that when you're curious in
life, it fuels you, it fuels you and gives
you that sense of both the wonder and the
awe.
So interestingly enough, I would say find
those places in your own life where you tend
to be most curious, Google may be one of them,
Burning Man is one of them for me, TED has
been one of them for me, the Sundance Film
Festival is one of them for me.
What helps take the blinders off?
Because what tends to happen in midlife, for
a lot of people, probably less so on this
campus, is that people put the blinders on
and that's when actually the curiosity starts
to go away and some of the happiness starts
to diminish.
I was really lucky, how many of you have heard
of Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi yeah, well a few
of you, and I'm gonna call him Mike because
that's what he likes to be called, Mike Csikszentmihalyi.
He wrote a book called Flow and when you hear
people talk about being in the flow or in
the zone, quite often they're sort of speaking
Mihaly Csikzentmihalyi's language, Mike Csikszentmihalyi
language.
The idea was that there's certain times in
your life when you actually get in the flow
where you just sort of feel like it's all
coming together and for 15 year olds it tends
to be when they're playing video games [laughs]
[laughter]
and interestingly enough if you look at the
components that create a sense of flow in
people's lives, very much so you'll see it
in a second.
Well, Dan actually helped me with this equation
because we were talking about flow and it's
a combination of skill and challenge, well
Mike Csikszentmihalyi mentored me, he invited
me to come up to his ranch with his wife Isabella
in Montana for three days and to just talk
about flow which was like the coolest thing
in the world.
And I was just there to learn, I was curious,
I was very curious and he showed me some of
his diagrams.
This I actually think is particularly appropriate
for people in the engineering world and people
who are dealing with the riddles of life.
On one axis, there's challenge; on the other
axis, there's skill.
If you have a lot of skill and very little
challenge you tend to be in the boredom place,
a lot of challenge very little skill you're
in the anxiety place.
This is what it looks like if you look at
the whole graph and the different emotions
you have.
And ideally what we wanna do in life is we
wanna get into the flow zone and the flow
zone is basically flow equals 1.0; skill divided
by challenge there's sort of a 45 degree vector
that actually sort of helps you understand
that's where it's ideal.
Actually a little bit off for those of you
more precise in the audience, it's less than
1.0 because what Mike Csikszentmihalyi shown
is that you actually want a little more challenge
than skill because what actually sort of ratchets
you up to that 45 degree angle as far to the
right as possible, is something that sort
of says you're challenge is a little bit higher
than your skill and you're just sort of going
like this, like this, and like that.
So qualities that do that for people, it's
when you have clear goals that define success
and as we look at the six that I'm gonna show
here just think about 15 year olds with their
video games.
[laughs] Immediate feedback so that you can
incrementally adjust the constant balance
between your skill level and your challenge,
the ability to focus exclusively on the activity
through completion, a loss of sense of time
and self consciousness when you're in the
midst of the work, and the activity being
intrinsically rewarding so that there is an
effortlessness of action.
So that's flow in the form of an equation.
And the last one I'm gonna introduce before
I just sort of then sum up and we have questions
and I'm gonna talk a little bit about why
it is relevant to leadership is thriving.
Now as I started to do my research on the
idea of emotions in the form of equations,
I did find not just that Marty Seligman happiness
equation, but I found a few other equations
as well.
I found an equation by a woman named Barbara
Fredrickson, famous psychologist who'd written
a book called Positivity; she has a website
called positivityratio.com and she'd shown
that in the context of people's own personal
lives as well as in an organizational context
if you wanna get into that sort of thriving
cycle, we're very familiar in our lives of
being in that downward spiral, the downward
spiral is when everything just sort of like
domino theory, everything gets worse.
Well, there are upward spirals too, the New
York Giants seem to be in an upward spiral.
The book Moneyball talked about the Oakland
A's winning 20 games in a row 10 years ago
or so.
So we sort of can get into upward spirals
in our lives and organizations can, too.
In rowing there's a phenomena in rowing when
a crew is all rowing at the same time in unison
and it's just magical, the boat almost lifts
out of the water, it doesn't almost it actually
starts to lift out of the water.
They call that swing in rowing circles so
it's an amazing physical experience is that
actually the unison of people being together
at the same time creates almost a thriving
phenomena that the boat comes out of the water
and therefore there's less friction and the
boat goes even faster.
Great organizations do that well.
And the reason why Barbara Fredrickson said
the ratio needs to be three to one, three
to one positive to negative, is because Daniel
Kahneman who has a great new book out Thinking
Fast and Slow, he's shown with Amos Tversky
a few years ago that frankly we have this
loss aversion thing, we have a tendency when
we have a bad experience in our life and then
we have a comparable good experience in our
life, the bad experience has twice of an emotional
impact on us as the good experience.
It's like our brains are sort of I don't know
Velcro for negativity --
[laughter]
and Teflon for positivity.
So that's part of the reason why the ratio
needs to be three to one.
And in organizational context that's what
they've been able to show.
Now for me, I used this in my own company
when I really understood this.
We had our top 15 executives, we would do
an executive committee meeting every week
and during a recession, those executive committee
meetings were terrible.
I mean you know what I'm talking about, I
mean things are better now, but about two
or three years ago at Google, yeah it wasn't
a whole lot of fun seeing some of the financials
and some of the results and there's a lot
more pressure.
And so these meetings we would have, was 90
percent negative stuff, 90 percent all the
bad stuff and about 10 percent the positive.
So I said, "Well I wanna actually leave this
meeting, this two hour meeting every week,
on a positive note."
Not to just to fake it but I wanted to remind
people that there's some good things happening
here.
So what we did at the executive committee
meeting is I said, "Starting next week, I
want you to bring in an example of something
that happened in the last week out there in
the field, one of our hotels, we have almost
40 hotels, come in and talk about something
that happened that was great and somebody
who deserves some extra recognition."
And so starting the next week we did this
and like only two people raised their hand
out of the 15, but each week we'd do it.
And it could be the bellman of the Hotel Rex,
one of our hotels in Union Square of San Francisco,
and it could be the hotel has only one elevator
and it went down for two days.
And if you have a seven story building [chuckles]
that has only one elevator and it's down for
two days you need a lot more bellmen because
you need people to schlep the bags up and
down the stairs.
So there's a guy who had his family in town
from New York and instead of actually spending
time with his family, one of the bellman worked
16 hours a day two days in a row because we
needed extra bellman service.
Now he got paid overtime and he might have
gotten thanked by his supervisor, but did
he think that somebody from the executive
offices like the head of marketing for the
company was gonna come across the street or
go over to their hotel and say thank you to
him, Joe the bellman?
Well, that's what we started doing and the
fact that we ended our meetings on a positive
note had three big positivity or thriving
things that came out of it.
Number one is we reminded ourselves that there
were some good things happening and frankly
when things are going badly you really do
need to remind yourself that there's some
things that are going well as well.
Secondly, Joe got the positivity, he got rewarded
and recognized by a senior executive in the
company and for the next 24 hours it was like
a stone in a pond the ripple effect of how
Joe felt about his life and around everybody
around him not just the employees he worked
with and the customers but when he went home
that night was a positive.
And then thirdly, the fact that actually it
was from someone from a different department,
that was our rule, if you're gonna go out
and say the thank you and you're gonna sort
of do the positivity, it couldn't be someone
from operations to say thank you to Joe, Joe's
in the operations department, the hotel operations.
So we had someone from marketing or from IT
go and say thanks to Joe and that was important
because it created some cross fertilization
in a difficult time.
So for those of you who feel like okay this
is a bunch of just nonsense, positive thinking
kind of stuff, well, look at a boat.
This is a sailboat and if you look at what's
above the water versus what's below the water,
the average sailboat has about three times
as much above the water, the mast, than what's
below the water, the keel, the bottom of the
boat and then the keel which is what sort
of helps to steer the boat to some degree
and that and the rudder.
So just from a physics perspective, the fact
that if you have an organization where all
you ever have is positivity and no one talks
about the negativity then you've got a sailboat
with ten times tall mast to one times tall
keel and that sailboat's gonna actually flip
over or capsize because it's a bunch of bullshit.
Excuse me, but it's just people giving positivity
to each other and not actually talking about
the negative; you gotta talk about the negative
that's the keel.
But you could also have a boat or an organization
where the mast is only one-third and the keel
is three times bigger than the mast and most
organizations are like that and then the senior
executives wonder why this damn sailboat won't
go very fast.
[chuckles]
[laughter]
So there's a physical side to this.
But let me just sum up by saying the following:
I was a CEO for 24 years.
When I went to Stanford Business School I
was the youngest guy in my class and the second
youngest guy in my class was Seth Godin, you've
probably heard of Seth Godin.
So Seth and I are good friends, have known
each other since business school, and Seth
knew he wanted to be a writer when he grew
up and I said, "I'd sort of like to be a writer
someday but first I wanna go out and be an
entrepreneur and maybe I'll be a CEO someday."
And one thing I said to Seth years ago is
he said, "Well what you gotta at business
school?" this is our second year of business
school, we wrote a book together in our second
year of business school, Seth and I did.
And he says, "Well what'd you need to do?
What skill set do you have to have?"
And I said, "I sort of feel like I have to
be a super human.
In order to be a successful CEO someday I've
gotta be a super human."
And what I really believe now 24 years after
being a CEO, doing it for 24 years, and there
are very few people who have been a CEO for
the same company for 24 years, the company
I founded, is it's not about being a super
human.
It's about being a super human and just realizing
that as the CEO of the company, this sounds
like a cliché, but you're sort of like the
chief emotions officer.
And let me explain that because some of you
are like, "Oh God, this is just agony."
[laughter]
What I mean by that is that the fact is this
is a Petri dish, this organization Google
is a Petri dish, your department is a Petri
dish.
We learned from Daniel Goleman 16 years ago
when he wrote the book Emotional Intelligence
that two-thirds of the success of business
leaders tended to come from their emotional
intelligence, their EQ, and about a third,
on average, from their IQ and from their level
of experience in their work.
So it was the first sort of, there was work
done before Daniel Goleman ever wrote about
this, but this is where it got popularized.
So 16 years later we know this.
Smart guy here in a different state right
there.
Matt Lieberman's a neuroscientist at UCLA
and he's proven the following: when you're
feeling anxious or angry or frustrated, when
you make decisions from that place of anger
or anxiety and you try to make a decision
in that moment, you're losing 10 to 15 IQ
points in the act of making that decision.
Now if I'm giving a speech to a non-Google
crowd I would say the following: "Some of
us in the crowd can't afford to lose 10 to
15 IQ points."
[laughs]
[laughter]
But at Google you can afford to lose 10 to
15 IQ points because you're all smart.
But the bottom line is this: is that when
we are making decisions in that reactive place,
think back to that Viktor Frankl quote about
the choice in our lives and the freedom is
actually responding to things not reacting.
When we come from a place of response as opposed
to reaction we are able, and what Lieberman
showed is if you just even name the emotion,
and when I introduce the idea of these equations
he says, "Well that's just taking it one step
further that's even better," you're taking
yourself from the amygdala, that fight or
flight part of your brain, the caveman part
of your brain, the part of your brain that
frankly is not so smart, I mean it's good,
it has its role in your life for sure, and
you're taking yourself to a different part
of your brain where more reasoning happens.
So it's a good thing.
And finally if you have never read the book
Connected by Nicholas Christakis I highly
recommend you read it, it came out two or
three years ago.
What he was able to show is that our emotions
are contagious and we already knew this.
If I go up and smile at Meng, he'll smile
back.
We have mirror neurons such that we sort of
end up aping each other, but also we have
socialization that means that whatever the
organizational environment we're in has an
influence on how we're feeling.
Not a surprise, but the truth is that the
fear is just as contagious as the flu.
And if you're a leader of an organization
and you don't understand that and you're fostering
fear in an organization that needs to be creative
and innovative, duh you're actually not doin'
a very smart thing about actually helping
to live up to their potential and use their
brain potential in a way that's actually gonna
be using their emotions to their maximum potential.
So just to sum up some of us in the room are
saying, "Well, I'm not a leader."
Well, you are a leader, you're a leader to
yourself, you're chief emotions officer [chuckles]
of yourself, you may have children and a spouse,
you may be the leader of your family, you
may be the leader of a department of three
people or five people.
Leaders are the emotional thermostats; where
we set out emotions have an enormous influence
on what the group feels about their experience
in the group.
According to some surveys 50 to 70 percent
of how a group feels about their experience
in a group comes back to how they feel about
the leader and how they feel the leader feels
about the group.
So I know this.
During the dot com bust, I set my emotional
thermostat high and our company did well.
During this downturn I had a really hard time.
Ultimately I sold the majority share of the
company to John Pritzker whose father started
Hyatt, he's a billionaire, and it was great.
It allowed me to go spend more time writing,
researching, etcetera.
But I was not in a place where I was a very
good emotional thermostat for the organization
and I could see it.
So I've seen it on both sides where I've been
great at it and where I wasn't great at it.
So the most neglected fact in business in
my opinion, is that we're all human.
And I learned how to actually play with a
computer and start workin' on a computer at
Stanford and then at Stanford Business School,
I learned how to drive a car in high school
at driver's education.
But I never learned emotions, [chuckles] I
never had a class on emotions and that's what
my intent has been is to help us understand
the ingredients [sound of tapping on suitcase]
in this piece of baggage that we're carrying
around with us for a lifetime.
And if you can understand the ingredients
of anxiety or the ingredients of joy or happiness
or the ingredients of authenticity then you're
able to influence those ingredients a little
bit more.
So you may have your own emotional equation,
if you do, oh that's the book Emotional Equations,
she's got them right here, Books Inc. has
them, and you may have your own emotional
equation that you wanna come up with and you
can go to our Facebook site and actually post
your emotional equations there.
And with that thank you, I'm gonna say thank
you and them I'm gonna open up to see if there's
any questions.
But thank you very much for being here today.
[applause]
So anybody have a question that's gonna scare
the hell outta me about the math side of this
thing?
Let me just say one thing about the math and
Dan was very helpful with this: in the book,
I'm very clear that the math is not perfect
and frankly, if you take an equation like
despair equals suffering minus meaning and
you invert it in a different way, it doesn't
work.
Some of the equations do work if you say,
it's like some don't work so I'm the first
to say don't try to actually get too precise
about this.
But what it does do is it helps you understand
the relationship between these emotions and
that's the part where it is a bit of a mantra
and it can be a mind instrument for you.
Yes.
>>female #2: So I'll start with a thank you
--
>>Chip Conley: Thank you.
>>female #2: this is really incredible.
There were a lot of equations there though.
Is there any that you would say is sort of
your number one that you pay attention most
to?
>>Chip Conley: Well let me just say this so
the one, it's like over the course of 25 years
we've created like 55 boutique hotels so people
say, "Which is your favorite?"
Well, my favorite's like the Phoenix, the
funky rock and roll motel in the Tenderloin
that's our like lowest end hotel because it
was the first.
So the first one that means to me that despair
equals suffering minus meaning is one that's
very meaningful to me on a daily basis and
has been very helpful for me when I'm talking
with friends who are going through a difficult
time.
The anxiety one is I think been the most effective
one in terms of in organizational context
of helping people to sort of say, "I'm feeling
this anxiety, what do I do with it?"
And the balance sheet, that anxiety balance
sheet is really valuable for people.
The one that recently has been helpful with
this book and sort of like saying, "Okay,
Chip you have a tendency to get too much into
the pursuit of things and why don't you enjoy
the little ride you're on right now," has
helped me to make sure that I'm not in the
denominator of the happiness equation too
often.
I mean those are some of the ones I've actually
presented to you, there's a bunch of other
ones, there's 18 that are presented in the
book in 17 different chapters and what I had
to do, because this could be just a silly
little parlor game if I didn't go out and
make sure that if I'm doing an equation on
envy and jealousy, which is one chapter, that
I spent time with experts in the field to
say, "Okay tell me about the nature of what
are the ingredients of envy and jealousy."
So that's what I needed to do and that's what
I did.
So thank you.
Yes.
>>male #3: Thank you.
This might be helpful for other Jewish people
in the room but I was wondering if you've
done any thinking about where guilt comes
from --
>>Chip Conley: Where what comes from?
[laughter]
>>male #3: Where guilt comes from.
>>Chip Conley: [laughs]
It's interesting guilt is one that I want
to do in the next, there's probably, it looks
because the book's doing well there may be
like a second version, that and trust are
like number one and number two, but I can't
tell you, I have not done my research yet
in terms of guilt.
Guilt is a fascinating emotion and so I promise
you it's gonna be in the next book because
it's one that I think is quite pervasive,
too.
Do you have any suggestions of what's your
equation for guilt?
>>male #3: [pause] Um --
>>Chip Conley: It has something to do with
your mother?
>>male #3: I think is has something to do
with how much responsibility --
>>Chip Conley: Yeah.
>>male #3: you take for something.
>>Chip Conley: Yeah one of the equations in
the book is regret and regret equals disappointment
plus a sense of responsibility.
And so actually I'm fascinated by regret and
remorse and guilt and shame.
Guilt and shame are interesting, the difference
between guilt and shame is guilt is I did
something wrong and shame is I am wrong.
And so all of that's fascinating to me and
so I just haven't done my research on it yet
so.
>>male #3: So great.
And also I was wondering quickly it seems
like Burning Man has been an big influence
on you.
>>Chip Conley: Yeah.
>>male #3: I've never been I'm hoping to go
this year and I was wondering if you could
briefly kind of share what about Burning Man
is so great or healthy or whatever.
>>Chip Conley: Yeah, let me say it's, everybody
is gonna have a different experience.
So and I'm on the board so I'm on the board
of Burning Man [chuckles] Burning Man has
a non-profit board and I'm on the board of
Burning Man and if you wanna read a funny
article --
>>male #3: Also how do we get tickets --
>>Chip Conley: I get tickets yeah --
[laughter]
that's a hard thing is there's now stupid
ass lottery that doesn't make a lot of sense,
that we're still figuring out so there's gonna
be some new announcements on that soon.
I think the thing I like about Burning Man,
what Burning Man gets a lot of attention for
is the drugs, the music, the nudity, but at
the core of what I think Burning Man really
speaks to is the creative and artistic spirit
and how that unites us and there's a spirituality
and a utopian sort of belief in the world
which I think is really, takes us back to
childhood, for me it takes me to that sense
of like wonder about what the world could
be like if these Burning Man principles were
lived every day.
So I love it for that, I hate the dust storms,
there's all kinds of other things that you
don't like about it, but more than anything
the creative spirit is what really drives
me to go almost every year.
>>male #3: Great, thanks.
>>Chip Conley: Thank you, yes.
Question?
>>male #4: Hi there.
>>Chip Conley: Hi.
>>male #4: Thanks so much for the talk --
>>Chip Conley: Yeah.
>>male #4: that was great and it's so meaningful
for how we show up as people and as leaders.
I was wondering though how you think impacts
customers and users?
>>Chip Conley: Yeah.
Well one of my equations I had ever before
I wrote this book or even started the research
was I had talked about it in my company is
disappointment equals expectations minus reality
and it's sort of one of the more basic equations
in the book.
Disappointment equals expectations minus reality,
think of it.
You are going on your honeymoon, expectations
here [chuckles] reality here, disappointment
or divorce.
So that's, there's times when I think the
equations can be very helpful and that one's
helpful for me when I'm talking to our marketing
department.
The marketing department wants to do everything
they can to paint a beautiful picture of what
the hotel's gonna be like and the web's gonna
tell us, but if we don't do a very good job,
an accurate job of telling the story, we are
going to create disappointed customers over
and over again.
So how do we improve the reality or make sure
that the expectations are in line with what
real really is?
So that's one of a handful of equations that
I think are relevant to the customer experience,
there's a few other ones, too.
I'm actually speaking at South by Southwest
in March and my whole talk is on emotional
equations for the customer experience.
So I'm in the process of actually writing
that speech so I'll figure that out and maybe
it'll be on line.
>>male #4: Yeah, please let us know.
>>Chip Conley: Okay, thanks.
>>female #3: Hi Chip, thanks --
>>Chip Conley: Yeah.
>>female #3: so much for coming.
Also I just stayed at my first Joie de Vivre
hotel, Hotel Irwin in Venice Beach --
>>Chip Conley: Oh yeah --
>>female #3: it was really awesome.
>>Chip Conley: I love the Irwin, it's funky.
>>female #3: Yeah, really cool.
>>Chip Conley: Yeah.
>>female #3: So I was wondering what opportunities
employees at Joie de Vivre have to learn about
these concepts and if so how you teach --
>>Chip Conley: Yeah.
>>female #3: them.
>>Chip Conley: Well, we have a Joie de Vivre
University and I actually teach a class on
emotional equations and started doing that
about two and half three years ago.
Senior leaders in the company have done half
day and full day retreats with me on our emotions.
So in essence what we've gotten to a place
is we realized, "Damn; we didn't have any
courses."
We had courses, half our courses in Joie de
Vivre University are skill based and half
of them are sort of lifestyle oriented: yoga,
meditation, search inside yourself kind of
things.
But we didn't have anything, we had zero classes
on emotions other than understanding personality
types which was a course on the, I always
pronounce it wrong, the Enneagram, we had
a course on that.
But we didn't have anything about emotions
and so we started teaching emotions classes
and they were the most popular classes.
So now we're teaching more emotions classes
and that's part of how we are trying to help
improve the emotional fluency.
See my belief is that emotional intelligence
is what Dan Goleman talked about and I love
it, but you could be intelligent about something
but not fluent.
I could be intelligent about going to France
and knowing the dialects of French and the
history and the origins of the language, but
I can't walk down the street and go into the
shop and actually speak it.
Or I can be great at actually critiquing someone's
film or their dance moves but I can't dance.
Being fluent means you can do it.
And so to me, emotional intelligence is great
and emotional fluency is a step beyond it
where you start becoming more intuitive about
how the emotions affect you and that's why
for me the equations are a step towards fluency
as opposed to just the intelligence.
So yeah, thanks.
>>female #3: Okay.
>>Chip Conley: It's how you use them.
>>female #4: One more.
>>Chip Conley: One more.
Yeah.
>>male #5: Hi, thank you very much for the
talk.
If we take, if we take equations at the face
value it looks like that it's important to
minimize disappointment for example --
>>Chip Conley: Minimize what?
>>male #5: disappointment, the suffering,
meaning, and minimize disappointment right?
So my question is what are your thoughts about
emotions and time because maybe there is a
time --
>>Chip Conley: Yeah.
>>male #5: for disappointment and then just
let it be and then not try to minimize it
at the moment.
>>Chip Conley: Well, there's a really interesting,
it's a very good question especially in the
context of regret and actually, at one point,
Dan and I were trying to figure out one equation,
I remember which one it was that had a time
factor to it and it was a little challenging.
But there's some emotions where the emotion
can get stronger over time, regret is one
of them.
It depends on what you regret but generally
speaking what has been shown is what we tend
to do we have somethin' called loss aversion
and we don't wanna actually, if you ask someone
whether you choose to, you have two choices,
no electric shocks on this one.
You can either choose to earn $200, we're
gonna flip a coin, if you guess the right
side of the coin you get $200, if you get
it wrong you get zero; you can either actually
flip the coin and get zero or $200 or I can
give you $100 right now.
Most people will choose the $100.
Why?
I mean the math of it suggests that, why it's
because they don't want the regret.
So that's one example.
Now if all of a sudden you say, "Okay," I
mean, there's a component where you can actually
add regret to it all of a sudden it goes back
to the math.
What they found over time is that people have
a tendency in the course of time to regret
what they didn't do in life as opposed to
what they did do and where they made a mistake.
So what's interesting about time is you have
to actually sort of factor it in for certain
emotions and know that with some emotions,
with most emotions, with time the emotion
dissipates.
And from a biological perspective, the biology
of an emotion in terms of physically what's
happening sensation wise in your body, it
lasts about 90 seconds.
But how we bathe in that emotion for a lot
longer than 90 seconds is what's interesting
and some emotions, like regret, actually can
get worse with time.
So long story short is that's a piece that
where it's sort of like the advanced class
of emotional equations is how do you factor
time in.
I didn't do it for the sake of this book because
it got a little too complicated and some emotions
were not relevant; happiness definitely trails
off over time around a particular issue.
So that's a long winded answer but it's a
good question because the truth is in the
moment we tend to actually feel, it's like
anything in life, when we're feeling that
immense joy or happiness there's this tendency
to feel, at that moment, it's gonna last forever.
And when you're feeling the intensity of the
despair in that moment, we think it's gonna
last forever.
And the truth is that our emotions are like
the weather, we're good external weather forecasters,
you knew it was gonna probably rain today
because a forecaster told you or you could
sense it.
We're not so good at our own internal weather
forecasting and we have a tendency to think
that if there is a snow storm today there's
gonna be a snow storm the rest of our lives
when we're feeling despair.
And the fact is weather comes and goes and
the best thing you can do with these emotions,
is to help them move through you and that's
the word emotion means; it means to move.
So, Dan.
>>Dan Russell: And with that, let's say thank
you to Chip.
Thanks Chip.
>>Chip Conley: You're welcome.
[applause]